how are you Steve don't do a good rip
our you I am doing fine i guess the word
is congratulations in a way but marshall
faulk and all the guys who I work with
who retired said you know that that word
sort of got them a little riled up his
congratulations the right word to say to
you right now Steve no I don't know I
guess I'll take it you know yeah it's
better to screw you who show up I beg
that you say that as if you've heard
that one before Steve oh absolutely I've
heard it you know so why now why now
Steve you know I just feel like why not
you know you know that there's gonna be
people who who have their opinions and
opinions are like the other end of you
everybody has one and so for me you know
it's just it's been a lot of thinking
and and coming up with a decision and
then after the decision is uh you know
just kind of letting it go kind of just
saying it letting it go you know it's
almost uh they say a lot of times you
know if you have some things going on or
if you have a problem to my write a
letter but never send it well this isn't
anything negative towards anyone else
it's just kind of me letting it go and
kind of getting off my chest and then
kind of just moving forward I do
understand some of the requests in the
media stuff that's going to come behind
it but at the same time I you know I
approach that the same where I approach
everything else if I want to do it I'll
do it if I'm not I'm not um but you know
just kind of less me lesson things go
and then and be filing with Steve Smith
joining me here on the program you are
one of the players who who is the
quintessential you only know one speed
you only know how to do it one certain
way and that's why you're so successful
that said what what about the process of
needing to gear yourself up to get to
that speed is causing you to say 15
years is enough in the NFL well I think
one of is a you know a great example is
you watch p
when you see things and you ask yourself
and I ask myself do I want to be that
guy don't want to be that guy who may be
in the next year too who desires that
who thinks they have the desire and want
to play for X amount of years do I feel
like getting up and moving from there do
I feel like going through this offer
like going through that and then my
answer is no I do not feel like doing it
it's not because I can't i just know and
i have a perspective of is it worth it
to me and right now if the answer is no
because I know why I would be doing it
and it has nothing to do with money it
just has to do with really is that fear
and the uncertainty of not knowing what
comes next and I know it's coming Nexus
is enjoyment and I look forward to that
you know some I ask me you know what
does it look like man when you run a
route you know what you're running it
the only difference with success and
failure in a row is a ponent is a
linebacker DB or safety is a coverage
but you know you have a finish line for
me this gives me a finish line and I
work well with finish lines and objects
and objectives and and so that's what I
feel like I'm at I know at the end of
whenever it comes it comes but I also
didn't want to be one of those guys
where I played and if it didn't go right
then you go well I'm retiring to go did
he quit because of this this this now
it's out there does it put pressure on
me absolutely it does because then
everything if I don't do this well see
that's why he's retired because you're
not he's he's older or he's not this is
like no our retirement cuz I get to
choose to so if let's say november
december and you're crushing it as you
have in your career there would how will
i would will be if you noticed i said
like you have in your career yeah okay
so there won't be a moment where you
pause and go maybe 16th I can do this
where I can gear it up in the non
playing season and get those workouts in
that I can't focus in that regard that
creep in on oh absolutely it crept in up
to the moment I walked up and talk to
the team and walked up to the podium it
did it to where I was walked working out
this year and my trainer he knew it my
wife knew we talked about in and but
then there's days where I go you know
for that split second yes but also have
a teenager who's going to be a upcoming
senior who is going to be this time next
year I'll be driving him off to college
let and I want to experience that I want
I don't want to have to ask someone can
I take my boy to college I'm going to
take my son to college and I don't have
to ask anybody and those are the things
that are important to me what are the
ages of your other kids somos de 17 my
daughter should be 14 in the and bottom
off mother son is 10 years old and then
my youngest junior he's one years old so
you are in diapers you are going off to
college I mean you are you are running a
parental gamut right here that loser I
have college uh starting of my daughter
menstrual cycle and hormones be a little
bit hormones and I got a poopy diapers I
have all I have everything covered and
oh yeah by the way I have a career um
you know and and so it's just all those
things I enjoy doing but it's also time
for me to settle down and come to
realization that something has to has to
give and if you wait long enough the
only things going to give is your
feelings because the harsh reality of I
can't do it anymore it's going to come
at some point yeah and you've got at
Denver week one right at Oakland week
yep now let's say Steve that you show up
in Denver and the Broncos want to give
you a going-away present Allah many
farewell tours do you accept the
farewell tour steve from from visiting
teams oh aight i'll give them I it'll be
a farewell tour for me but let me let me
be very clear I will wound damage and
puncture a lot of people on my way out
so that I sort of wanted because one of
my colleagues here on the set feels that
farewell tours like ones that Jeter
Mariano Rivera went on but he's also Red
Sox fan thinks that that's you know
making it about the athlete more than
about anything else where do you stand
on the concept of farewell tour Steve
Smith he did I said I I said I got all
let me tell you so I'm playing with
house money you know it's dangerous when
you play with house money mm-hmm you
don't have no regard so your office go
home all in mm-hmm I'm all-in with Yo Ma
with your money you know what they say
we playing with other people's money you
just be reckless you do stupid things
with it that's what i'ma do see those
money so you're particularly dangerous
this year is what your isn't what you're
saying Steve yes sir put the women the
children to bed now gonna be a good
night was there any thought at all of
you waiting one more one year saying I'm
done and then signing with the Panthers
at all was that it and it crossed your
mind at all and going out that way Steve
well I'm Salonika I was I'm under
contract with the Baltimore Ravens and
to be honest you know I'm not avoiding a
question I'm putting it like this it's
taking me a couple of months to get to
this decision I think I cannot say
anything just off the cuff that isn't
well is it methodically thought out on
and we'll make that decision when that
when i get to that but right now i'm a
baltimore raven i will operate and work
as a Baltimore Ravens okay did you
notice in your old camp that cam of all
people got into a fight a training camp
fight Steve did you see that I saw that
what you think well you know what oh I
guess that's good for them you know I
think they kind of like those players so
oh I guess it's all right i like it i
think i got a razem though he's the
first guy I've ever seen fight smiling
the whole time
so do you think this was uh was is this
is this in Cam's nature or is this a new
cam that we're seeing here Steve what do
you think uh I don't know mother
quarterback is Joe so I oh I'm not oh
god I worry about what's going on in
Baltimore okay you're just focused on
the task ahead I'm yep and the task and
the task ahead is to is to make sure
that everybody remembers your name after
you come through them one final time
have I given up proper I mean you don't
really have to even remember my name to
be honest I hope I hope I leave a
lasting impression where they uh they
give you that that a concussion test and
they give you a word to remember you
can't remember and in a confiscate your
helmet that's what I hope that's Steve
Smith senior say my name is essentially
what you want to say look let me tell
you something Steve I I've started doing
the NFL network thing in 2003 yeah and
you were in year three when that
happened so I have essentially seen your
entire career Super Bowls changing teams
at the Pro Bowls I've watched your
family get get larger as you add as you
had more and more kids with your wife
and I'm just thrilled to see you doing
it the way you want to do it Steve you
deserve a shave I know a lot of people
don't get the opportunity to do it not
and I've got an opportunity to do it but
you know one of the things I I want to
make clear is not a fair world tour okay
it is still bald man you know and I'm
not I'm not walking in in any Stadium in
any practice thinking it felt like well
man this is quote/unquote my last game
so give me you know give me some slack
you know I anticipate it's gonna be some
nonsense going on and I think it would
not be if it wasn't football all right
Steve can we chat with you as the as the
year goes along and and talk about
what's going on with the Ravens and
maybe just maybe when it's when it's
appropriate look in the rearview mirror
can we do that Steve yeah guys I gotta
check my schedule i do uh I am gonna
have some some some official visits with
my son okay to go on and I'm
excited to look forward to and you know
we got some schools here in Baltimore
that's polynomial ok that's uh that's
pretty good so he's uh I'm excited about
that too i've been trying to try to
nudge him a little bit but he's uh he
got looked at me sideways and told me
pump the brakes i said are you got it is
he the only one who could tell you to
pump the brakes or your IG and your wife
I'm well he's he just gave me the look
he actually didn't physically come out
of his mouth is it like your look is it
like your look does he have your
absolutely not it was more innocent it
was like uh you know what if yeah I get
you that but I mean you know I'm just
excited oh okay you know because it's an
opportunity you know it when you're an
athlete and you get to see you some
become a student athlete and then you
start to see this colleges like I saw I
tell you one of the schools here in
Baltimore yep oh cuz he play soccer is
uh John Hopkins mm-hmm and I'm like oh
hello you know what's the debate yet on
to me so he's kind of looking at me like
you know I get it dad but let me do it
and sure and I gotta respect that but at
the same time I'm also looking at it as
you could play football 15 20 years or
soccer however many years but having a
prestige degree from John Hopkins that
bet bettin that comes every generation
or so dr. Smith start that's what we're
talking about here dr. Smith that's what
vb4 Johns Hopkins I know that be good
stuff Steve you listen and then and then
of course you've got what Sesame Street
all cued up oh did we r right now was a
Disney we're on Disney what are you what
are you in Disney what do you got uh
well we got a Mickey Mouse Playhouse oh
yeah yeah mooska moose whatever it is
I'm right there with you Steve meeska
mooska mickey mouse yeah that's the way
it goes and then you know then the
clubhouse comes up out of nowhere yeah
and then all of a sudden here comes to
tools and we're off and running you know
what it means yep you know hey thanks
for calling in i preciate it all right
let's Steve Smith senior